hallo mein name ist luca und herzlich
willkommen zu project wales ich bin
dieses auto da unten wir können hier mit
diesem auto herumfahren und auch
stehenbleiben drive through the paint
shop to change kalle sind karg braun wir
können mit diesem auto verschiedene
sachen machen wie beispielsweise einen
looping fahren
es hat geklappt und das ganze soll er
quasi die realistische simulation sagt o
das ganze soll sonde cassini watch it
sein und man kann auch andere autos
auswählen aber wir fahren jetzt erstmal
mit diesem ding und wir haben jetzt die
farbe pink war unten recht wenig wie
schnell ich fahre und in welchem gang
ich bin nicht fahren dem ich gerade 7000
km h oh mein gott
ach du heilige scheiße was hab ich hier
mein gott luca das ist doch der kann man
auch nicht ein
luca warum mache ich denn immer ich habe
so einen leichten links drei habe ich
das gefühl weiß auch nicht woher das
kommen könnte ich versuche mal die rote
lampe hier mitzunehmen kann so schlecht
ausgegangen ich versuche jetzt das
looping oben in der mitte zu verlassen
mal schauen ob ich das kann ich auch mal
landen ja mein auto sieht auf jeden fall
komplett gesund aus so wie sich da wo
bin ich
es ist ja nicht so
dies auf jeden fall eine realistische
simulation
leute ich bin schon nach 1000 km h die
zeit ist gekommen um mein gott wir haben
ein monster auto aber das allererste was
mit diesen dinge machen werde es mal
eben kurz die farbe ändern komme ich da
wo ich bin echt
ich hasse dieses spiel wir haben glaube
ich auch space sogar noch an
wieso sind da oben zwei loopings dann
muss ich erstmal muss ich diese roten
balken hochfahren und aber über h
das ist jetzt das ist jetzt nicht wahr
ich bin nicht wirklich da gerade drüber
gesprungen dann fahre ich halt ganz cool
einfach ihr rechts den schönen kreis rum
weil mit dieser blöden bei der damen und
herren ich bin oben angekommen und werde
jetzt mit an schwung dieses looping
bestreiten und ich werde es hinkriegen
denn es gibt nur einen menschen auf
dieser welt erschaffen kann mit diesem
ich hasse dieses auto nur ich kann es
schaffen nur ich kann es schaffen dieses
looping mitzunehmen wir fahren mit
vollgas hoch die geschwindigkeit geht
natürlich ein bisschen runter aber wir
sollten es mit dieser geschwindigkeit
ein auto sieht von oben gar nicht sehr
gut aus aber wir haben noch ein drittes
vehikel und zwar gute schaut mal hier
sogar so controls ich hab was ich ab
slowmotion ach du heilige scheiße und
ich fange gerade ganz langsam dieser
kleine steigung hoch damit ich hier oben
direkt drauf super mit gute muss es doch
schaffen diese scheiß looping
mitzunehmen route kommen glaub an dich
du musst einfach nicht glauben dann ist
es auch alles kein problem hier und wir
haben es geschafft und jetzt rüber in
anderen looping
ein reifen vorne rechts ist einfach
losgelöst vom auto sieht sehr schön auch
wenn ich nicht diese treppe hier
irgendwie leicht so gute des super gute
was tust du und mit vollspeed gegen ich
muss aufhören sonst mache ich das noch
komplett kaputt wenn euch das video
gefallen hat würde ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen